welcome back to Las Vegas now if my coma
environmental technologies can treat
Buckingham Palace I think they can treat
your home or your business they provide
a simple solution from removing bacteria
viruses mold odor and other unwanted
things that can affect your air quality
and it's made right here in Las Vegas
here's our conversation please introduce
us to your company this is my coma
environmental technologies so is a
company funded with the base intention
to help the planet purifying the air so
we have a unique product that is a nano
technology and we call it if an nano
coating for photocatalytic
nanotechnology covering the McCarran
Airport is already working on it
applying the coating in certain sections
and they plan to do the whole entire
beautiful Airport has it for the past
two years they have marketers
testimonials because the restaurant
North Vegas they mentioned that people
is not calling sick that often that they
used to be before and a wonderful friend
Oscar De La Hoya a golden key which is a
wonderful man for the community he is
applying the coding genes how do you
apply the coding and what does it do
specifically okay what you do is you
apply the coding as my husband says us
it would be a pain basically we pull the
ceiling you can use a roller you can use
a brush or you can use a sprayer that's
very simple once you put it on it stays
put forever and ever and ever
we guarantee 15 years but there is no
reason why it shouldn't stay there for
much smaller now I want to give you an
example how it works let's say I sneeze
right now now they are some droplets of
water that will come out of my mouth and
in those droplets of water there will be
the viruses and because the there is
always an updraft because the air down
below is becomes warmer from belphemon
from my body it will carry the droplet
it will carry the viruses up towards the
ceiling and if the coating is up there
the virus will get trapped there and
will get zapped immediately can we use
in our homes can we use it in our
facility use it in your home it can be
used in homes it can be used in
hospitals it can be used in restaurants
of course besides killing viruses and
bacteria it does all kinds of other
things like it eliminates pet odors
cigarette smoke unit we manufacture the
product here in the state of Nevada and
is great for the whole entire world
saving the planet from Las Vegas all
right with coma environmental
technologies you can find them at 7:02
951 one four zero one or mokou MoDOT us
las vegas now we'll be right back